[Música]
la reforma que Polonia le hizo a su
sistema judicial en 2019 es ilegal
afecta la independencia de los jueces y
va en contra del Estado de derecho de la
Unión Europea todo esto fue lo que
determinó el tribunal de Justicia del
bloque de los 27 el 5 de junio se
pronunció contra la modificación Aunque
no es la primera vez que lo hace en
julio de 2021 ya le había ordenado a los
polacos que pararan la comisión que
crearon para investigar a los jueces por
sus decisiones sin embargo Polonia
desacato el fallo y desde entonces se
comenzó a debatir la opción de que
Varsovia quisiera apartarse del bloque
como ocurrió con Reino Unido y por eso
Muchos hablaron en su momento de un
polexit legal pero ahora la decisión del
tribunal es más fuerte para entender un
poco veamos parte de lo que dijo el
tribunal
al encomendar a la sala disciplinaria
del tribunal supremo de Polonia cuya
Independencia e imparcialidad no están
garantizadas la autoridad para
pronunciarse sobre casos que tienen un
impacto directo en el estatuto de los
jueces y asesores judiciales así como en
sus funciones
la República de Polonia incumplió las
obligaciones a las que está obligada en
virtud del artículo 19 1 para grafo 2
del tratado de la Unión Europea
pero esta no es solo una decisión
judicial sino que se trata de un nuevo
capítulo de La batalla que ha emprendido
Polonia en contra de Bruselas desde que
el partido derechista y euroescéptico
ley y Justicia asumió el poder en 2015
se irá a Polonia de la Unión Europea o
acatará el fallo del tribunal y se viola
del Estado de derecho como tema de
Bruselas o es la independencia y la
soberanía polaca lo que está en juego
como Afirma a Varsovia para todas estas
aristas en el debate hoy nos acompaña
desde Madrid Jose gagón profesora de ie
University en Madrid y en Ciudad de
México está Armando García
internacionalista de la Universidad
Nacional Autónoma de México y magister
de la Universidad Autónoma de Barcelona
bienvenidos y gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros y a ustedes nuestros
televidentes les recordamos que también
pueden participar en el debate y lo
pueden hacer dejando sus comentarios y
preguntas en Twitter Facebook e
Instagram donde estamos como arroba
Franz 24 raya al piso e s pueden
comentar con la etiqueta numeral el
debate f-24 que ven en sus pantallas y a
mí me encuentran como arroba
maríacleaguirre pero no solo estamos en
las pantallas también encuentran
nuestros podcast en Apple podcast
Spotify deezer y TuneIn
comienzo entonces dándole la bienvenida
a Maggie Jose Gracias por estar aquí con
nosotros y para entender un poco sobre
todo para nuestra audiencia
latinoamericana cómo explicar En qué
consiste el fallo del tribunal de
justicia de la Unión Europea
Muchas gracias María por su pregunta si
me permite antes podría explicar un
poquito porque el tribunal de justicia
de la Unión Europea puede decirle a un
país que su sistema judicial es
contrario al derecho de la Unión Europea
porque al final es lo que dice de nuevo
el tribunal de justicia en esta
sentencia Pues bien como sabéis el
estado de derecho y en particular la
independencia judicial son valores de la
Unión Europea
es
inscritos en varios artículos de los
tratados y también en la carta de
derechos fundamentales de la Unión
Europea
Y esto es una obligación que tienen los
estados candidatos si quieren entrar un
país quieren pagar en la Unión Europea
claramente tiene que cumplir con estos
valores que dice el tribunal de justicia
en esta última sentencia que son parte
de la identidad de la unión por lo tanto
es una obligación a la hora de ser
estado miembro de la unión pero esta
obligación obviamente
sigue siendo obligación una vez dentro
de la Unión Europea y por lo tanto el
tribunal
comprueba que efectivamente los estados
cumplan con sus obligaciones relativas a
los valores de la Unión Europea y entre
los cuales está el respeto del Estado de
derecho y por lo tanto dentro del Estado
de derecho se hay una referencia también
a la independencia judicial
y Por qué es tan importante que
tribunales de los estados miembros sean
independientes bueno porque son los
jueces ordinarios del derecho europeo y
si y que el derecho europeo y la la
aplicación uniforme del derecho europeo
se basa también en la confianza mutua
entre los estados miembros y por lo
tanto si hay vulneración de la
independencia judicial en un estado
miembro pues esto puede vulgar también a
su vez el derecho propio y la propia
aplicación del derecho por lo tanto es
muy importante que los estados miembros
garantezcan puedan garantizar que sus
tribunales sean independientes y esto
creo que que es importante
explicar esto como
digamos de fondo como cuestión de fondo
para entender porque el tribunal de
Justicia se puede meter en estos en
estos ámbitos porque al final cabo los
estados miembros lo que dice Polonia lo
que ha dicho antes usted que Polonia
reivindica su soberanía obviamente los
estados también lo dice el propio
tratado
los tratados respetan la identidad
nacional de los estados miembros pero de
nuevo esto se tiene que hacer dentro del
respeto a su vez del derecho de la Unión
Europea y precisamente lo que está en
cuestiones este derecho porque en dentro
de la Reforma judicial que hizo Polonia
en 2019 se creó una comisión que le daba
el poder para investigar a los jueces
del tribunal supremo de Polonia y además
dependiendo de la decisión que ellos
tomarán podía incluso aplicarle
sanciones multas económicas o incluso
retirarles la inmunidad y además hacía y
los obligaba a publicar en línea y
publicaban en línea toda la información
de los sobre todo relativo así
pertenecían o no algún partido político
y alguna ong el argumento de Polonia Es
que esto era para contrarrestar la
influencia comunista en el país y para
garantizar una mayor imparcialidad de
los jueces sin embargo tal como lo
estaba explicando amarillo se no siempre
se ha visto Así o no se ha visto así
desde Bruselas que lo ha visto como una
afrenta a la independencia judicial y
que hace parte del Estado de derecho
Armando García bienvenido aquí al debate
y gracias por estar con nosotros en
medio de todo este panorama que
comenzamos a a poner sobre la mesa aquí
en el debate Cuál es su opinión sobre la
decisión del tribunal y también sobre la
reforma que impulsó Polonia en 2019
Buenas tardes Muchas gracias por la
invitación un placer aquí tendríamos que
poner como decía la profesora Marí
también otro contexto la reforma
judicial de 2019 se inscribe también en
el problema que se presentó en el 2021
cuando el tribunal constitucional de
Polonia dijo que el derecho comunitario
era anticonstitucional contrario a la
Constitución Europea y este es el punto
clave de la sentencia del tribunal de
Justicia Porque si bien el gobierno
polaco hizo una reformas a Estancia
reforma judicial para eliminar la sala
disciplinaria como se llamaba y
transformarlo en una administrativa
seguía o sigue siendo vigente la
posibilidad de poner sanciones a los
jueces que interpreten y que respeten la
primacía del derecho comunitario y este
es el punto fundamental porque en el
2021 ya se inició un procedimiento por
infracción frente esta sentencia del
tribunal de Justicia
tribunal constitucional Perdón polaco
que dijo que el tribunal que el derecho
comunitario era inconstitucional que no
era compatible los artículos uno y
diecinueve del tratado de la Unión
Europea y este es el punto porque como
bien decía la profesora Maguey se
encuentra en el Core de la identidad de
los valores que comparten los estados
Miembros al ingresar a la Unión Europea
un derecho comunitario el aquis
comunitario que ellos aceptan aplicar a
partir de la atribución de las
competencias la idea el argumento que
señala el gobierno polaco de la pérdida
de la soberanía en realidad es más un
argumento ideológico porque no hay
ninguna pérdida de soberanía los estados
miembros de la Unión Europea en su
soberanía atribuyen competencias a la
Unión Europea y en este contexto
Tendremos que recordar también
Cuál es precisamente la ideología del
partido de la injusticia quien es quien
gobierna actualmente
Polonia un partido que se ha ido
construyendo en esta visión
euroescéptica y antieuropeísta
justamente y hablamos precisamente de
Esa visión euroescéptica que representa
en Polonia el partido ley y Justicia
pero que además no es el único porque
Polonia ya se ha Aliado con Hungría y lo
hizo recientemente este año para hacerle
frente a las visiones en materia
Internacional del bloque sobre todo de
países que tienen más fuerza dentro de
la Unión Europea como Francia o como
Alemania
todo esto hace parte entonces de un
intento de Polonia por ir en contra de
como lo dice Armando ese Core ese centro
de lo que es la identidad de la Unión
Europea
me Temo que sí me Temo que sí
Y además dentro de
estas de estos de estas democracias que
podíamos que se llaman o que se
denominan y liberales Pues quizá el
poder judicial es todavía lo que
puede garantizar justamente el estado de
derecho y y se ven en algunos estados no
solo en Polonia también en otros estados
como
los gobiernos
pueden intentar socavar el poder que
tiene todavía el poder judicial para
mantener el estado de derecho y esto es
desde luego es preocupante y preocupante
por estos estados pero también por la
propia Unión Europea
que en este en este sentido está muy
dividida y el pulso que existe entre la
comisión Europea y Polonia
y que vemos reflejado en las sentencias
del tribunal de Justicia pues tiene
varios vertientes de allá una ante el
tribunal de justicia y en este sentido
el tribunal de justicia de la Unión
Europea asiste el papel de gargante de
los valores de la Unión Europea esto es
muy importante sabemos también que el
tratado de la Unión Europea el artículo
7 permite
privar en última instancia a un estado
si va en contra de estos valores pero
este artículo 7 que permite hacer esto
al fin al cabo Aunque ha sido
el procedimiento ha sido empezado contra
justamente de nuevo Polonia y Hungría
nunca ha llegado a buen Puerto Por qué
Porque hay problemas políticos para que
se lleven a a buen Puerto y existen
muchos mecanismos y cada vez más
mecanismos a nivel europeo para intenta
obligar los estados no solo Polonia a
cumplir con sus obligaciones en relación
con el estado de derecho
para intentar mantener una cohesión
entre todos los estados aquí hay algo
importante y usted hace alusión a la
independencia del poder judicial como
una de estas barreras o uno de estos
bloques que puede hacerle frente a la
intención de Polonia de apartarse o de
ir en contra de la intención comunitaria
de la Unión Europea sin embargo en 2021
cuando por primera vez el tribunal de
Justicia del bloque de los 27 se
pronunció y le dijo a Polonia usted
tiene que acabar esa comisión que está
investigando a los jueces a la
independencia judicial la miss el mismo
tribunal supremo constitucional de
Polonia dijo esas decisiones son
ilegales y van en contra de nuestra
Constitución e incluso llegó a decir que
el tratado de la Unión Europea los
tratados de la Unión Europea iban en
contra de la Carta Magna polaca es decir
en Polonia Esto está trascendiendo el
partido de ley y Justicia e incluso en
este caso la misma corte constitucional
o el mismo tribunal supremo está
diciendo nosotros tenemos la soberanía y
tenemos que cumplir nuestra Constitución
Cuál es su postura frente a eso Armando
y si teniendo este precedente se puede
esperar que esta vez Polonia haga caso
omiso de nuevo a la sentencia del
tribunal de la Unión Europea
difiero en el hecho de que mencionas que
trasciende al partido de injusticia
Porque desde el 2015 que fue la primera
vez que el partido le di Justicia obtuvo
La mayoría en el parlamento en las dos
cámaras del parlamento polaco y en la
presidencia inició un proceso para tomar
el control de las instituciones entre
ellas el poder judicial y de hecho hizo
toda una reformas para transformar el
poder judicial y el nombramiento de los
jueces del tribunal constitucional parte
del gobierno no es independiente y a
partir de ahí de allí de hecho saltaron
las alarmas en Bruselas justamente como
en términos de esta independencia del
poder judicial No creo que son no es que
trascienda al tribunal al partido de la
injusticia sino que el partido la
injusticia en esta ideología en términos
de
retomar la soberanía y el control
también ha retomado de expandir su
ideología
controlar las instituciones en este caso
las instituciones judiciales y por eso
es una forma en que Polonia intenta o
sigue haciendo frente a lo que considera
y considera el ingenionismo de Bruselas
justamente no en términos cuál podría
ser el resultado aquí podríamos
mencionar como bien decía la profesora
María esta idea de antieuropeismo
euroecepticismo pero tiene esta
naturaleza diferente en términos de
estar al interior de la Unión Europea
Porque si bien el procedimiento el
artículo siete como bien lo mencionaba
la profesora es un elemento fundamental
político Sí porque es el consejo por
unanimidad quien decide que hay que
sancionar al estado y quitarle su
derecho a voto en el consejo ni Polonia
ni Hungría van a votar en a favor de
sancionar a sus a socios o aliados en
este sentido de quitarle la naturaleza
de identidad que este sería el punto
fundamental porque Polonia y el Hungría
se presentan como los defensores
de la identidad
real tradicional de Europa no frente a
lo que representa el internacionalismo
de Bruselas y esta visión distinta entre
los nacionalismos o la identidad
nacional que defienden Polonia y Hungría
que usted nos explica versus el
internacionalismo de otros países como
Alemania España Francia más que yo sé
usted cree que esto puede llegar a
implosionar el bloque de los 27
no creo porque hay otros intereses en
juego
y de hecho lo vemos con la Guerra de
Ucrania
Polonia
ha recuperado creo un cierto
protagonismo en la en la Unión Europea
hagáis de la de la guerra en Ucrania
obviamente lo que pasa en el tribunal de
Luxemburgo esto es otra historia pero
creo que que no es no es porque hay
divergencias en relación con valores
fundamentales de la Unión Europea que
existen hoy el día el riesgo de que
implosione la Unión Europea porque
repito hay otros intereses en un juego y
creo que
la Guerra de Ucrania ha hecho o ha
permitido que Polonia
reencuentre un sitio dentro de la unión
aquí usted Menciona un punto que ha sido
fundamental y es Ucrania dado que
Polonia no solo ha sido uno de los
aliados más fuertes de kiev y dentro de
la misma Unión Europea ha promulgado la
idea de apoyar constantemente a Ucrania
con armamento con ayuda humanitaria
etcétera y además Polonia se ha
convertido en uno de los estados de la
Unión Europea que más ha recibido a
migrantes ucranianos Armando Le quiero
preguntar a usted esta posición del
gobierno polaco frente a la ayuda de
Ucrania ha hecho que la comisión europea
sea de alguna manera más dócil con él
podríamos decir que sí ciertamente desde
el inicio de la invasión rusa Ucrania
digamos los enfrentamientos judiciales
entre Polonia y la comisión europea
fueron bajando de hecho la sentencia
viene por parte del tribunal de Justicia
no de la de la comisión europea que ya
había
descongelado algunos fondos de
recuperación económica para Polonia
No es que sea más dócil porque
recientemente hay un nuevo
enfrentamiento la presidencia sueca
quiere
actualizar la reforma de la de la
política migración asilo seguir con esta
redistribución de los migrantes y
polonias está oponiendo a la idea de
recibir más migrantes porque
Efectivamente es el país que más
migrantes se refugiados ucranianos ha
recibido y se opone a recibir más y a
posibilidad que se maneja desde el
bloque comunitario que si no recibes más
pues tengas que contribuir con
presupuesto y Polonia lo considera esto
como un castigo
no es que la comisión sea más dócil pero
hay que tener en cuenta como bien decía
la profesora Maggie no el peso que tiene
Polonia a partir de la invasión ruso
Ucrania Pero además el peso que en sí
tiene antes de la invasión rusa Ucrania
Polonia ya era el país más importante en
Europa del este dentro de la Unión
Europea es el quinto país con mayor
población después de la salida de Reino
Unido pasa a ser uno de los cinco
grandes de la Unión Europea del bloque
comunitario Sí entonces tiene es un país
que tiene una importancia
fundamental habría que mencionar como
punto importante si la comisión es dócil
a larga en los tiempos judiciales son
más largos en otoño de este año hay
elecciones generales en Polonia Y
nuevamente podría haber un cambio de
gobierno Son mencionados puntos
fundamentales que sin duda tenemos que
tratar aquí en el debate y son uno el
dinero que ha congelado Bruselas hacia
Polonia un poco a medida de castigo por
toda esta reticencia en sus reformas
judiciales y dos las elecciones Pero
antes de eso le quiero dar la palabra
amarillo y preguntarle precisamente
sobre si usted cree que la postura de la
comisión ha cambiado y aquí hay un dato
fundamental y es que si bien la comisión
europea abrió el caso legal contra
Polonia por la reforma judicial en
diciembre de 2021 Fue en Febrero de 2023
cuando la comisión que hace las veces de
la rama ejecutiva de el bloque de los 27
fue febrero de 2023 que la comisión lo
demanda demanda Polonia ante el tribunal
de Justicia es decir un año después de
que empezara la invasión Cómo
interpretar esa movida legal
exactamente tiene toda la razón esto es
una cosa también que quería mencionar
antes en febrero del 23 es decir febrero
de este año la comisión europea
después de de hablar con Polonia de
pedir de pedir explicaciones ha decidido
llevar a Polonia de nuevo ante el
tribunal de justicia de la unión
en oración con lo que llego su tribunal
constitucional en octubre del 21 por
considerar que esto de nuevo es
contrario a la primacía
al principio de primacía del derecho de
la Unión Europea
entonces decías que la la y la y como
sabemos la comisión europea es la
guardiana de los tratados la que vela
junto con el tribunal de Justicia pero
la que controla que los estados miembros
primero cumplan con sus obligaciones
derivadas del derecho europeo
y la comisión europea en este sentido es
la que lleva los estados ante el
tribunal de justicia y después del
tribunal de Justicia va a ratificar o no
lo que dice la comisión Europea y puede
eventualmente multar a los estados
Cuando incumplen con sus obligaciones
decir que la comisión europea Es más
dócil desde la Guerra de Ucrania
me cuesta deseo porque yo creo que como
ha mencionado usted este el hecho de que
la comisión lleve a Polonia ante el
tribunal de justicia de nuevo
por culpa de lo que dijo su criminal
constitucional yo creo que no es una
demostración de toxicidad más bien todo
al contrario creo que hay distintas
agendas una agenda política pero también
hay una agenda que de cumplimiento de
obligar a los Estados a cumplir con sus
obligaciones y que esto sigue hay un
proceso Hay un procedimiento que hay que
seguir y es lo que ha hecho la comisión
europea Entonces le quiero contra
preguntar digamos que hay una doble
línea de la comisión europea frente a
Polonia de un lado tenerlo como Aliado
político frente a un hecho tan
importante para todo el continente como
la guerra en Ucrania pero por el otro
seguir sus luchas legales por la reforma
judicial
es posible que así sea porque justamente
por lo que ha dicho usted que el hecho
de que un estado vulné valora es
fundamental es de la Unión Europea pues
esto constituye un riesgo grave para la
cohesión misma de la de La Unión
sin embargo como decía antes pues hay
otros intereses en juego y la comisión
tiene que hacer este papel de de una
parte de su papel de guardiana de los
tratados Pero por otra parte claramente
un papel político y valorar el papel que
juega actualmente Polonia en el
conflicto y en la guerra que hay en un
caña el papel de apoyo clave sin fisura
aquí como dijo usted
Ahora quiero hacerle una pregunta
Armando sobre uno de los puntos que
usted trató y que resaltamos
anteriormente Y es estas sanciones
económicas la Unión Europea congeló 35
mil millones de euros que tenía
destinado para Polonia para que se
recuperara después de toda la crisis
económica a raíz de la pandemia del
covid 19 y además de esto en julio de
2021 cuando el tribunal constitucional
polaco desacató la sentencia del
tribunal de Justicia europeo el tribunal
de Justicia le impuso que por cada día
que esta comisión que le ordenó
desmantelar por cada día que siguiera
continuando Polonia debía pagar un
millón de euros cada día y luego rebajó
estas sanciones a medio millón de euros
y al momento Polonia estaba acumulando
una deuda de más de 500 millones de
euros que es un dinero que se le está
reteniendo de los fondos que Bruselas
tenía destinados para enviarle a Polonia
Cómo interpretar
estas sanciones económicas es un poco
como amarrarle el cuello Por así decirlo
a Polonia y asfixiarlo un poco
económicamente para forzarlo a que
cambie su sistema judicial
justamente tiene que ver con lo que
mencionábamos no de la docilidad las
cuestiones judiciales políticas la
comisión Europea el poder ejecutivo de
la Unión Europea tiene en el presupuesto
comunitario en los fondos comunitarios
el mayor control que puede ejercer sobre
los estados aquí habría que hacer una
distinción una cosa son los fondos
congelados a partir del programa eune
generation que es el programa de
recuperación económica que es el que se
congeló a partir del mecanismo de
condicionalidad de que los estados deben
de cumplir el estado de derecho etcétera
etcétera que es donde están congelados
la mayoría de los fondos Los 35 mil
millones de euros a los que tenía
derecho a Europa Polonia aproximadamente
otro caso otro cosa son las el dinero de
las multas que impuso el tribunal de
Justicia europeo que se pagan o se sacan
del presupuesto
comunitario que es plurianual de siete
años que se construye 2021
en lo que cual de lo que le
correspondería a Polonia de ese
presupuesto es donde se
me pagan por decirlo de ahí se guardan
las las multas que tiene que pagar al
tribunal por la sentencia del tribunal
de Justicia europeo habría que mencionar
también un punto muy importante en esta
cuestión del dinero al día de hoy y
desde el 2004 Obviamente el ingreso de
bolonia Polonia ha sido el estado que
más se ha beneficiado de los fondos
estructurales de la Unión Europea
Yo sé Cómo interpretar entonces estas
sanciones y teniendo en cuenta lo que
nos dice Armando que Polonia es el
estado del bloque de los 27 que más se
ha beneficiado de los fondos
comunitarios
Cómo interpretar las emociones bueno
aplicando también de nuevo es una
aplicación de
de lo que que permite hacer ahora el
derecho propio en particular en el
reglamento el nuevo reglamento de
condicionalidad
y también la comisión hace esto porque a
su vez
tiene gestión por parte del parlamento
europeo paga a hacer este tipo de cosas
o sea que no hay que olvidar también el
papel del parlamento europeo en este
sentido en gestionada la comisión para
que para que a su vez presione a
Polonia le Quiero contratar algo porque
la comisión europea ha recibido críticas
de actuar lentamente Y es que si Polonia
hace esta reforma judicial en 2019 en
diciembre 2021 la comisión europea abre
el caso legal y solo hasta febrero de
2023 la lleva ante el tribunal de
Justicia del bloque Se demoró para usted
la comisión en actuar No no es
exactamente esto si me puedo permitir
la la nueva ley la ley que que que que
que que que que que que la comisión
europea pidió a
Polonia que suspendiese es una ley de
del 2020 o que de
lo tenía del 2020 y después a partir del
21 o sea que tampoco mucho tiempo
después Pide al tribunal de Justicia que
le ordene a Polonia porque esto no lo
puede hacer la comisión misma pide la
comisión europea Pide al tribunal de
Justicia que ordene la suspensión de la
ley
al no actuar Polonia la comisión europea
vuelve a pedir unas medidas cautelares
al tribunal de justicia y en este
momento le pide que como medida cautela
o provisional multi Apolonia por día de
infracción y es lo que he mencionado
usted el millón de euros al día pero en
fracción que después en abril del 23 se
convierte en medio millón al día
por lo tanto en este sentido Yo diría
que la comisión europea no sea
[Música]
no sea alargado en reaccionar frente a
esta ley y después entre tanto en el
octubre del 21 es cuando el tribunal
constitucional polaco
emite este este fallo donde considera
que
que que que la que Polonia no está
obligada por el principio de primacía
del derecho de la Unión Europea lo que
va claramente en contra del derecho
europeo y ahora la comisión europea
decide en febrero del 23 lleva de nuevo
a Polonia ante el tribunal de Justicia
por lo que dijo su tribunal
constitucional en octubre del 21
No creo que yo diría que que los tiempos
no son tiempos extremadamente largos
también la comisión tiene sus sus
tiempos de negociación a su vez con con
los Estados miembros antes de
llevarles ante el tribunal de Justicia
para ir redondeando ya porque se nos
acaba el tiempo en el debate quiero
preguntarles un poco sobre Qué puede
pasar en Polonia porque esta decisión
del tribunal de Justicia llega pocos
meses antes de que en el país haya
elecciones nacionales para elegir a su
presidente y Andrés duda el líder del
partido ley justicia se enfrentará
probablemente a otros candidatos y la
pregunta es Qué puede pasar puede
cambiar el ajedrez político en las
elecciones de Polonia y sobre todo
teniendo en cuenta que dentro de Polonia
hay un gran recibimiento a ser parte del
bloque europeo en las encuestas muestran
que la mayoría de la gente quiere seguir
perteneciendo a la Unión Europea y ahí
parlamentarios y hay políticos dentro
del país que abogan por esto Qué puede
pasar y además en medio de todas las
disputas que tiene Polonia con Bruselas
porque no es solo la reforma de la
justicia sino que también Polonia ha
tomado unas decisiones que contrarían
esos esos principios europeos por
ejemplo ha declarado zonas libres de
personas lgbtiq más junto con Hungría y
recientemente está discutiendo la ley de
influencia rusa para supuestamente
reducir y controlar la influencia de
Rusia en la política de Polonia algo con
lo que Bruselas están desacuerdo
precisamente porque se puede convertir
en una persecución de la oposición con
todo este panorama Qué puede pasar a
futuro en Polonia y Cómo afecta esto a
Bruselas Armando
justamente como mencionabas el el punto
fundamental estado derecho uno de los
valores del centro de la identidad de la
Unión Europea esta comisión en la ley
que quería crear una comisión
parlamentaria de investigación para la
influencia rusa en el periodo 2007-2022
que puede ser utilizada justamente
contra la oposición y de hecho como se
conoce ahora en Polonia contra un
personaje específico de la oposición que
es el líder del partido plataforma
cívica que es un partido conservador
digamos del grupo del centro derecha
europeo del grupo popular europeo que es
Donald trucks que ya fue Primer Ministro
y fue con presidente del Consejo europeo
de la Unión Europea y él es el candidato
o el que la persona que tiene más
posibilidades de ser candidato de la
plataforma cívica justamente las últimas
elecciones las del 2019 2020 si bien
volvió a ganar el partido de la justicia
ya no obtuvo la mayoría en el senado
perdió escaños en el en la cámara de
diputados justamente no Y entonces es
esto en otoño del 2023 el papel del
Donna stock simplemente mencionar el
domingo una manifestación en Varsovia
donde hubo más o menos trescientos mil
personas
manifestándose en contra de estas
políticas que está llevando a cabo el
gobierno actualmente y como bien lo
mencionabas en los últimos
eurobanómetros señalan más o menos entre
el 55 60 por ciento de la población
polaca confían más en la Unión Europea
que en su gobierno nacional
Cuál es su conclusión de Cómo
interpretar lo que pasará en Polonia en
relación También con Bruselas
Pues también este este fallo del
tribunal de Justicia puede ser utilizado
de dos maneras para demostrar que
efectivamente no no hay Independencia
Hoy hay una falta grave de Independencia
judicial en Polonia pero también a su
vez los políticos como han hecho algunos
de ellos En Polonia Pueden decir veis
estos jueces de Luxemburgo nos nos dicen
a nosotros como tenemos que organizar
nuestro justicia cuando nosotros cuando
Polonia es un país soberano O sea que
que se puede utilizar este fallo en un
sentido
u otro que consecuencias tenga no sé si
este fallo en particular tendrá una
consecuencia específico Pero es verdad
que este fallo es uno de de los
múltiples que ha habido esto no lo hemos
mencionado pero la saga polaca en
relación con la reforma de la justicia
esto ya tiene muchos años los premios
las primeras sentencias dentro de la
justicia declarando que Polonia tenía un
problema con su sistema judicial son ya
del 2019 O sea que ya hace muchos años
como se dice en español Llueve sobre
mojado no
Así es el nombre del equipo técnico debo
decirles que se nos acaba el tiempo pero
les agradezco a majillo sega got y
Armando García por acompañarnos en este
debate la producción del programa estuvo
a cargo de Luis Fernando Montes y la de
los invitados con Tania Herrera ustedes
Siguen con más 24
[Música]